I see Gary's your name Gary Gary Allan  Cole from Chicago Oscar show stealer  Gary from Chicago opens up about Jimmy  Kimmel's prank that made him an internet  sensation surprise  tourist Gary Allan Coe and his fiancee  Vicki gush to eat tea over being part of  Hollywood's biggest nights after the two  were selected at random from a tour bus  to unknowingly attend the Academy Awards  on Sunday I had that too of that  experience it was surreal when I saw it  I'm not starstruck I'm seeing all my  favorite actors and Gary and Vicki  dished on their favorite moments of the  night including when Jennifer Aniston  gifted Vicki a pair of sunglasses these  are my sunglasses so it's a wonderful  experience being kissed by being married  on television at the Oscars to Gary Koch  all of the excitement came just three  days after Gary was released from prison  anybody can change why not me  for more on his new lease on life tune  into ET Wednesday night  you  [Music]